who did it better hashtag 99 who was i
comparing abs with her Oh
Renaldo hi I'm Jesse lingard about to be
quizzed on my own social media
what was my caption to this fall yeah
it's about it's about Ashley Young Oh
animal out there today
Blanding he stayed away who did it
better
hashtag 99 who was i comparing abs with
yes Oh Bernardo a little bit a little
bit believe you night mentality gasps
what am i reacting to in this caption
[Music]
funds for the advice hashtag go he did I
say it was like I wish charities are
saying like oh just keep enjoying
football I always play with a smile in
your face and I just just give me the
right advice really just leaving me in
the right direction do you still think
you think he is the greatest of all time
yeah it was sick I might even Camp Aaron
enough one messy when how they were
wrong with you in your team guys you
gotta take him all in really I don't
know I would say one what and I always
believed in never give up the free lands
were on hashtag get into England which
England player was the only one not
standing when we are
because he missed his pen and it was
just that relieved that we scored it
straight through these librarian yeah Oh
take us through how are you feeling
about this
I was Shh I was next you know I was sick
I wasn't that I thought oh my gosh
you know what you practice in many ways
on yeah yeah I just hit in the same
corner let have your own carnival
well I was I wasn't being missed
alright what's guess what scared me I'm
alone weighs got a pigeon Pole know what
one funa billion archive laws of them
think it's not much just that someone
was that she's good she's got the tea on
because he'll take a long time to get
back oh wait nobody was against Ronaldo
oh yes soda hi I'm Jesse lingard and I
know my social media I don't know
[Music]